what was that you can buy a lot of
haunted things from eBay a lot of them
are dolls most of them are dolls another
kind of haunted item you can get from
eBay is haunted jewelry I decided to buy
a piece of haunted jewelry off of ebay
wear it and see if I experienced
anything paranormal and I found a
haunted bracelet
the woman is selling the haunted
bracelet said she was a collector of
haunted items and haunted jewelry nine
years ago she went to Italy and she went
to a flea market she went to a stand
that was selling antique jewelry and she
said she felt energies coming from some
of the items at the jewelry stand so she
picked up this bracelet but when she
picked it up the Italian man who was
selling the jewelry didn't want her to
buy it he didn't really speak much
English but apparently he said no good
cursed I guess my question is if he
doesn't want anyone to buy this cursed
bracelet why does he have it out of his
jewelry Stan why not keep it at home or
get rid of it maybe the curse is that he
can't get rid of it I don't know the
woman tried to explain to the man that
she's a collector of paranormal items
and that she could handle it so she
bought the bracelet and took it home
when she took the bracelet home it
started showing up in weird places
around the house where she definitely
hadn't left it she said the temperature
would drop when she was wearing it or
when she was around it she felt like
whatever spirit possessed the bracelet
was trying to feed off her energy she
said she wanted to get rid of it because
she felt like it was possessed by an
entity that she didn't want to deal with
anymore the bracelet came in the mail I
have it in this envelope
look bust out this cursed bracelet okay
it is smaller than I thought it would be
don't be mad at me ghost I just thought
this was a bigger bracelet okay so the
woman who sold this bracelet says she
has no idea how old it is because
there's no markings on it I'm gonna wear
it and we're gonna see if anything weird
happens so I actually do wish that there
was like a ghost inside this bracelet to
help me put it on because it's one of
those bracelets that's really hard to
get on without
somebody's help I have placed the
bracelet onto my wrist it's pretty hot
in here but this bracelet feels oddly
cold against my skin it feels very cold
but it could just be because it's super
hot in here that anything metal is going
to feel very refreshing I do like the
tiny people on this bracelet they're
very cute this looks like George
Washington oh no am I gonna be cursed
now that I touched it I don't know I
just got a chill you didn't I didn't and
they just cut like it my Jill I've been
wearing this bracelet for maybe 30
minutes and I just feel so tired
something is stealing my energy I don't
know if it's a ghost but I'm definitely
tired something super weird did happen
to me and I have no explanation for it
somehow I got lipstick all over my
computer and I swear to God I did not
kiss my computer it's not on my hands
there's not lipstick on anything else I
have no idea how I got lipstick on my
computer it's super weird I just got
home it's about 8 o'clock I'm still
wearing the bracelet normally I have a
rule that I don't bring haunted things
into my home but I broke the rule by
wearing this bracelet so that's not
great
I'm definitely way more tired than I
normally am if there's a ghost sucking
my energy with this bracelet it's doing
an amazing job I feel kind of relieved
you take off the bracelet it is nice to
just stop wearing an evil bracelet for
the day so I'm definitely on edge being
home alone with the haunted bracelet
every time I hear any noise I'm just
like what was that I am hearing some
very unusual noises that I've never
heard before they're like a weird
vibration going through like the Attic
which is not ideal I'm trying to just be
chill about it but there's a cursed
bracelet just hanging out where I sleep
whenever I'm scared I like to just look
out the window across the street at my
neighbors and I can always see their TV
through the window and I'm just like ok
the neighbors are watching TV
everything's chill I keep wanting to
throw the bracelet outside every time I
hear a weird noise this is why I don't
bring haunted things into the house
don't buy haunted bracelet I'm just
recording where I'm leaving it in case
it's in a different place in the morning
I hope that it stays right here I
thought maybe when I woke up this
morning and came out to the living room
I would see like a ghost child and I did
not see that so my bracelet thankfully
is exactly where I left it
right on top of my wallet one of my
cabinets is weirdly open I definitely
didn't leave it open so either my
husband or a ghost did this so I've had
kind of a rough morning I'm wearing the
bracelet I woke up at 6 a.m. to try to
go to the DMV to renew my driver's
license my train was late and it took
away longer than it's supposed to even
though I got up two hours early to go to
the DMV I was still two hours late to
work so I don't know is it the curse of
the bracelet I've been wearing this
bracelet all day a few bad weird things
did happen
[Music]
maybe this bracelet is cursed if you're
scared of ghosts and you want to get
over that fear by something haunted from
ebay like a bracelet hang out with it
and then if nothing scary happens maybe
you'll feel a little bit less scared and
then if something scary does happen
you'll know that your fear was justified
and you'll feel smart for being afraid
for the record I'm never bringing this
into my house again
[Music]